all right guys i'm sorry i'm sorry
for leaving the stream earlier
i apologize okay
i forgot my door lady
was bringing me food
okay
i'm gonna finish this video really quick
so for anyone that wasn't here before
this guy was talking about
why
girls hook up with losers faster than
they hook up with you can you believe it
why would they do that
anyways but i know that she slept with
some
fat idiot douchebag
no problem like that so like what the
hell is going on here right
well
the sexual action threshold goes up
higher when she perceives a dominant
alpha guy
why is that some not all the time but
sometimes why does that sometimes happen
so it sometimes happens because women
have a protective
nature
about them when it comes to being alpha
widowed
a lot of women have no idea what being
alpha widowed means if you explained it
to them they would look at you like you
were
you know had some sort of mental
disorder
and they will never admit or understand
this not every woman of course but a lot
of women they're just not in touch
with what attracts them oh my god okay i
had this experience
where i would be like oh no i could not
date him he would ruin my life
and i didn't really know what that meant
but he's articulating it pretty pretty
good
rod like reject a guy because they're
too hot i swear to god it's a thing
it's a thing
to men we see that all over the place
women just make oh i really want this
quality guy that quality guy and then
she's sleeping with somebody else none
of the qualities she talks about right
so women make goofy decisions and that's
part of their nature it's a whole
thing that would take another a lot a
long time to explain but i've done other
videos on why that is all right so women
don't necessarily know they don't they
couldn't tell you what being alpha
widowed meant you don't get that but
here's the thing
there's an innate part of them that
understands that if they get blown away
by a guy that they can't keep
they're gonna get hurt or damaged they
don't know what alpha widowing is yeah
no true
true sir
yeah because okay if i this is this is
how i think this
is if i have a guy that's an i'd
consider myself let's let's give me a
six i
i usually think i'm a five but let's
give me a six okay if there's a guy
that's at eight
nine ten that shows interest in me
i'm like why
one i'm like what's wrong with you
and i don't mean that in a mean way i
just mean like you could be with a model
why wouldn't you pick the model
and the second thing is i'll see a girl
hotter than me and she couldn't keep him
how the hell am i gonna think that i
can't like
they know that they will go i don't want
to get hurt
whereas if they sleep with a douchebag
that isn't that high in smv
but just high enough to
make them
have an okay time sexually and make them
feel good about themselves sexually
they say yes to that guy because it's
safer this is the whole thing and i did
a video on this if you search search it
up i'll try to i did i said randy orton
was hot to find it and put it in the
description of this video at some point
okay
but if you guys remind me i definitely
will but i talked about how women yes
sleep with alphas
there's women who sleep with betas for
transactional reasons
but there's women who sleep with guys
who are in this third category which is
i call it the maybe the douchebag alpha
or the loser the loser alpha category so
in other words he has enough
traits
of being an
[ __ ] where he's attractive with to
women enough where they think i'll be
all right with them i'll have a good
enough time them sexually so she has
some attraction but she is not blown
away by him by any stretch
and she'll sleep with that guy easier
than sleeping with super high value guy
some of the times unless super high
value guy has status
so if that guy is like a celebrity
status a girl will sleep with him
because then she can she has those
bragging rights you know so it's it's
i've slept with this person's status
even if she's not attracted to that guy
that much she'll sleep with that guy
because of his status so that's often
where she'll make the decision but the
guys the status are not these super
alphas either right so that's a whole
another kind of category it's status
hunting or women who's okay this i've
never heard anyone articulate this
better
because i swear to god i've always said
i like my guys a little bit ugly i'm
sorry i do
a little bit or something like a little
because i'm like i don't i don't want
you to ruin my life i'm sorry i i know
this is out of a place
of insecurity okay
it absolutely is
i'm just being honest
um
i want to keep streaming i'm kind of
tired
but i felt bad i didn't
let me let me just do a trans
someone said something about trans sport
like okay is it bad that i don't think i
need to study like i don't know any of
the science behind this stuff
but i don't need a study to tell me that
it's not fair like i don't even
understand why we're having this
conversation
oh but let's see what blair white has
the thomas the only swimmer to stay
under 28 seconds on every lap yeah she
was really solid this morning in the
prelims i didn't think she took a hard
stroke the entire 500.
leah is a woman trans women are women
and she deserves to compete among other
women
here we go hey guys welcome back to my
channel so i feel like i want to title
this video i can't [ __ ] believe we're
still talking about this because this is
one of those topics that i feel i can't
believe we're still talking about this
either blair
we're on the same page
like a healthy society would have came
to a solution for
like
years ago
but i'm wrong leah thomas i have
probably never gotten more requests to
talk about like anyone than leah thomas
the trans swimmer but before we jump in
just a reminder that you can meet me and
see me speak at the better discourse
conference in fort worth texas april
23rd along with a list of other speakers
from all over the political spectrum
it's gonna be an amazing time and i
would love to see you there link for
tickets in the description so if you
have an instagram or twitter and you are
even remotely glued into political
discourse you definitely recognize his
face leah thomas the trans swimmer
actually the first trans woman to win
the championships for the ncaa and baby
the internet is on fire about this and
that's probably predictable because
anytime trans athletes make the
headlines there's going to be
a big conversation happening but i've
never seen a trans athlete get as much
backlash as
leah thomas as she
should i have to say
we are living in a south park episode
like look at this you cannot tell me
this is fair what the [ __ ] this case is
so clear-cut it's so black and white to
the point where leah ranks number 462.
462. why do they even count that far
back when you're ranking in a sport i
don't get it 462 in a male competition
and then number one in a female that
it's just comical it's it's a mess leah
you know you tried it
trevor banks tyrannosaurus rex the thing
that really set twitter off is the
pictures of the finalists which
a picture speaks a thousand words i mean
it's so ridiculous that if someone were
to come out and say that leah was some
sort of plant
and the goal was to make trans women and
women sports look ridiculous oh my god i
was thinking this i had this thought the
other day like what if
leah thomas was literally just doing
this to make everyone look dumb and then
after she competes for how many years
she's like look
i'm a republican i just wanted to see if
i could do
and to prove a it i would believe it
because this is like a cartoon i
literally have an easier time believing
that this is some sort of plant in a
long con to discredit the trans movement
then i do that the ncaa just let this go
and saw no problem up until the point
where leah snatched the title
so the policy for trans athletes by the
ncaa transgender student athletes will
need to document sport specific
testosterone levels beginning four weeks
before their sports championship
selections starting with the
2022-2023 academic year transgender
student athletes will need documented
levels at the beginning of their season
and a second documentation six months
after the first they will also need
documented testosterone levels four
weeks before championship selections and
the gag of it all is that leah was only
on hormones despite going through the
entirety of male puberty and then
transitioning in her 20s
only on testosterone blockers for one
year in the summer
of
2020
like guys you cannot tell me
that this is not a dude i'm sorry i had
completed
my
one year of
testosterone replaced or sorry
testosterone suppression under
um
hrt they approved everything and i was
clear to compete on the women's team
as someone who's been on them for
seven or eight i could tell you the
first year
about all they do is make you cry a lot
they don't really do
jack anyone who thinks one year on
hormones and you start in your 20s after
developing as a male for your entire
life up until that point if you think
it's doing anything to your body in that
short amount of time i'm sorry but
you're just mistaken in fact i'm still
seeing changes in my body seven years
after the fact so the idea that after
one year you're suddenly on a level
playing field with biologically female
athletes i literally don't think you can
become on
a level playing field i don't believe it
i don't i'm sorry
i'm sorry guys trans woman having
developed the entirety of your male
puberty male skeleton aerobic lung
capacity heart size muscle mass bone
mass like
are you i can't with how stupid people
are i've actually long since accepted
that when it comes to the topic of
hormones 99 of people are complete
idiots when it comes to this topic they
have no idea what hormones do and don't
do they think it's like a light switch
like oh you took estrogen you're
women not like what that's not how it
works people also seem to think that
testosterone and estrogen levels are the
whole sum of what a man and woman is
that it's like if the levels are the
same then that's just everything else
the same
like sex differences is not some
abstract concept that we have to really
sit here and like figure out and debate
and go over and explain to people these
are things that like you just inherently
know from living in the world and seeing
people using your eyes thank you i don't
need a study
i have been saying this i don't need a
study to tell you that this [ __ ] is not
fair
it's just common sense you only need one
of five senses to look at this picture
and figure out what the [ __ ] is going on
so much to the right
thank you thank you
of the entire community i did weigh in
on this and i tweeted
do not underestimate the amount of
justified contempt this creates for the
trans movement i'm trans and this pisses
me off i can only imagine how the rest
of the world feels and i completely
stand by that and make no mistake it is
justified contempt no rational human
being looks at what happened here in the
case of leah thomas and 99 of other
trans athletes and says that's fair no
guess what happens people start to build
resentment for that people don't like
that the trans movement has literally
the worst marketing and pr out of any
other group movement
that i've ever seen in my life like who
the [ __ ] really sat down and said okay
here's what we're gonna do to make
everyone get on board with who we are
we're gonna tell them they have to
accept sterilizing children they have to
be okay with ruining sterilizing
children oh my women sports and if they
don't want to because they're
transphobic
sounds like a great plan
like the most frustrating part of it for
me is that all of these things that the
community defends tooth and nail because
i guess they feel like they have to they
have
all to do with actually supporting trans
people and being accepting of trans
people and allowing people to make
decisions with their bodies they have
nothing to do with it to act like you
can't support trans people but also see
an issue with like the leah thomas thing
with 12 year olds getting double
mastectomies if you think those things
are mutually exclusive you're a fool
fellow trans people it is not necessary
to defend these things in fact it is
counterintuitive to the extreme nothing
is taken from me as a trans person by
saying yeah the leah thomas thing is
messed up and it's not that hard to say
but yet and still so many people in the
community and activists that speak on
our behalf are so oh my god this is i'm
so tired of unathletic men speaking for
men and unathletic women who don't
compete anymore and haven't competed in
years speaking for the current athletes
in sports guarantee okay girls won't
publicly say this because we don't like
to guarantee you survey girls and say
should trans women be allowed to compete
in our division and they say yes or no
and no one knows who they voted for i
guarantee
these [ __ ]
would not let trans people in i
guarantee so insistent on dying on every
single little hill that pops up i guess
it just blows my mind that the community
is incapable of understanding the
concept and thank you shane for
recommending my videos also guys if
you're enjoying the stream
send a
donation i know i hate to be that [ __ ]
always asking for donations but
i'm going to um all donations i don't
even keep money at this point i'm very
broke
i put it all back into the channel like
i just bought probably two grand worth
of equipment the other day so donations
are very much appreciated thank you i
want to bring in now griffin maxwell
brooks they're a member of the princeton
diving team who identifies as non-binary
griffin thank you for joining us an
asterix swim in her own lane what do you
make of that
um
i think it's all nonsense if i'm being
oh my god
bro like you cannot tell me this is not
a dude
you can't
like what the [ __ ]
bro
honest i don't think there's any need to
exclude people further i think that um
the demonstrations surrounding leah
thomas have been already abhorrent and
incredibly harmful
to the status of transgender people as a
whole and i also think that it's not
practical to create like an open
category um or just to further identify
trans women as different or other in
these situations what the [ __ ]
because you are different you are other
that's exactly what you are
um
leah is a woman trans women are women
and she deserves to compete
i swear to god these people are left
woke-ism makes you delusional
delusional
other women i like how they never offer
a tangible argument like at all it's
always just reverting back to the
talking points trans women or women end
of story don't ask me any more questions
and it's kind of like
what a great help you are my friend and
what exactly is the issue with being
different
because it seems to me that the whole
argument is that trans people trans
women don't want to accept they are
different from women
okay and i don't even care like what
trans people do like you could have
every right
sorry not the bathrooms and it's not
like blair but i'd be cool to share in a
bathroom with you i swear to god but the
issue is that you gotta protect people
from the crazy ones the people that take
you to the extreme
like the dudes that have been on
testosterone for six months i'm sorry i
don't want them in my bathroom
but like 90 percent of [ __ ] i don't care
do what you're gonna do
and what i've never been able to get a
straight answer from these people about
is why is being different than women
bad like why is that inherently a
negative thing why am i supposed to feel
less of myself
because i am different than biological
women why what value judgments are you
placing on yourselves and tell them sis
tell him place on me by insisting that
me saying that i'm different is somehow
a bad thing because in my world being
different actually makes you more
beautiful more intriguing a cooler
person in general who the wants to be an
npc wants to be just like everyone else
it's the exact same thing as people who
say we have to destigmatize mental
illnesses and then if you even hint that
gender dysphoria a neurological
condition that actually affects your
mood affects your quality of life and
exists in your brain maybe it's
something to do with being a mental
disorder
then it suddenly we can't call it that
why is it because you think there's an
inherently a negative problem with
having a mental disorder because i don't
judge autism i don't judge depression by
the way there's a shockingly low amount
of female athletes that actually speak
out against us and i have to kind of
check myself and remember that not
everyone's outspoken like i am me
me oh my god me
i'm not everyone wants to be talking
about this but i feel like this really
is time for female athletes to just
start speaking up and talking about this
and being like hey this isn't fair
because if you guys aren't going to
defend yourselves it's really hard to
defend you not that i won't but you're
making it harder i'm with you [ __ ] i'm
with you you know i see some people
saying that leah technically didn't do
anything wrong because leah's playing
within the rules and this is true this
is absolutely a fact it's not leah's
fault that the rules are so loose that
she's allowed to compete however i call
bs i think lee is a bad person i think
there's something to be said about
i think so too i was saying this i think
leah's either trolling or a bad person i
swear to god you cannot be a good person
and take that title away from a girl who
worked her whole life knowing damn well
you don't deserve it i'm sorry
i just mean it
sportsmanship integrity and wanting to
represent your community in a positive
way because at the end of the day leah
hurt the women in the competition leah
heard the credibility of her own
community let's just say a children's
wrestling league forgot to explicitly
write in their rules that adults could
not compete and then suddenly some 200
pound man came and started wrestling
kids and jacking up all these kids would
you think it's wrong or would you say oh
well you know what there wasn't a rule
against it so everything's fine no you
wouldn't very good example of this i'm
in the gym all the time right there's no
rules written by my gym that i go to
that pre-op trans women cannot go into
the women's showers and changing rooms
and be exposed among biological women
there's no rule i could do it if i
wanted to but i would never in a million
years do it first and foremost because
i'd be mortified for myself that's
humiliating for me but i can't think of
anything than going into a space being
so selfish and narcissistic that you
completely throw out the concept of
making other people feel uncomfortable
thank you
thank you
oh my god thank you this [ __ ] i i [ __ ]
with you blair i [ __ ] with you in that
way specifically and just i'm saying
blitz is a term of endearment i just you
know
that would make me a person
oh but great segue leah thomas
apparently doesn't care it's been
alleged that leah goes fully exposed in
the locker rooms at her university
without a care in the world apparently
there's been complaints i would kill
somebody i swear to god i would kill
someone about it and these complaints
have been completely ignored by the d.a
by the school because god forbid
anyone's feelings get hurt actually
specifically god forbid leah's feelings
get hurt to hell with the other girls
you know now i want to transition
no pun intended to a little bit of a
lighter you know part of the story
because when i tweeted i actually got a
lot of traction and i was met with a lot
of replies from other trans people and
despite the fact that so many trans
people do insist on dying on this hill i
really wanted to reach you guys some
tweets from other trans people and other
allies of trans people that feel
differently in reply to me
oh i know i'm trans and this is unfair
like let's stop pretending this is fair
can you do a video on this
i am now and you're in it my trans
partner expressed the same feelings
yesterday it can be hard enough gaining
acceptance though most people we meet
are cool but situations like this push
well beyond what is reasonable or
logical and unfortunately create far
more of a negative backlash 100
and it's a self-fulfilling prophecy
because you have all these trans
activists crying about how there's so
much hatred against them they do things
to
ignite those flames and i even who has
lived my life with almost virtually no
transphobia in my life ever even i feel
the tension when i'm around people these
days when these topics come up and
they're scared of what i'm going to say
even as someone who's very outspokenly
against a lot of my god and the other
thing that's crazy is like
you'd be surprised how many people agree
with you like i'm starting to put out
this type of content you'd be surprised
the amount of people that you would not
expect that come up to me and are like
thank you
thank you i feel it i see it i hate it
it's disgusting i'm trans and i support
trans people in sport ellie stop
what are you
okay what did i do okay wait i have to
be a situationalist here and this is
simply ridiculous while there are many
trans people without a significant
advantage she clearly is not one of them
the living justification of every
argument against as a trans myself i'm
with you oh yeah guys like this video
and send donations if you can all money
is being
donated towards
a new i want to get a new chair in here
i'm running out of money ellie what the
[ __ ] hold on
what
child
what
oh my god
ellie come here
come here
what are you
it's
oh
the audacity of this dog i would agree
my grandson is trans and so is his
fiance and both of them do not agree
with this never hated trans people been
around them since i was a child a trans
couple in my cosmetology class were the
only ones who weren't [ __ ] hell i'm
an og blair fan but we as a society need
to realize that biology is real so i
just wanted to not just be entirely
negative in this and paint this picture
a false picture of that oh i see she's
mad at her
oh my god
oh my god this dog
well trans people are on board with us
because it's just not the case and you
know especially in my comment sections
you're always bound to found trans
people that do agree with me so i'm very
glad they're out there and i do
really appreciate that i'm not one of
the only ones speaking out against this
there's already so many people that are
gonna be in a predisposition to say that
this trans community is some clown [ __ ]
let's just be honest so why are you
gonna go turn it into some actual clown
and give them what they want what's the
what's the what's the game plan here
maybe i'm just not filled in on the game
plan maybe you know my community is
playing some sort of long game that i'm
not aware of but it's not working so far
so maybe fill me in if there's some
elaborate master plan and this is all
just part of it because as of now i'm
thinking that you guys are your own
worst [ __ ] enemies i love you guys
follow me on twitter and instagram
because i post on there way more than i
do on here so you have to follow those
to keep up with me and i'll see you in
the next video bye guys
ellie i gotta make my own voice heard
too on this video
she really is doing that
okay let's
oh look there's me on the screen
oh
okay guys i gotta go to bed
it's like 3am
um
well
love you guys as usual um
i'm gonna go deal with my crazy ass dog
um thank you for the donations i
appreciate you guys i don't know
reactions from me are not gonna be
common but we have some big
announcements coming up on the channel
soon
okay is that coming at my life right
look it's called a struggle stream for a
reason
okay
i got my dog i'm about to kill so i need
to go